Michael I've seen films that have two
nemesis working against the hero but how
about two heroes in a film it is that's
really done well yeah okay that's done
and it's perfectly fine it's primarily
done in two kinds of movies buddy movies
and love stories or romantic comedies I
just that's three kinds but if you have
two heroes two protagonists all that
means is that everything I've talked
about in this interview about the hero
and the heroes
six stages and the hero's goal and
heroes Arkansas one has to apply to book
so take a movie like pretty woman you
have to equal heroes meaning they
equally are the main characters they
both drive the story forward they're on
screen and equal amount of time and so
on and they as is typical in romantic
comedies each of them has two goals his
goal is to put together a deal for the
shipping yards or something and that's
why you hired her to pretend to be his
girlfriend and he starts to fall in love
with her so his second goal is to win
her love her goal is to make 3,000 bucks
by pretending to be his his girlfriend
until she gets the $3,000 that's her
finish line and she's falling in love
with him so her other goal is to win his
love and so now they're both pursuing a
finish line and at the end either
they'll be together and achieve the goal
or they won't be and they'll fail and
then for each of them there must be
those five turning points and you must
be able to divide them into those six
stages and the training points will
occur very close together sometimes the
turning points are identical because
when they first meet is the opportunity
for both of them and when he hires her
that's the change of plans for both of
them and so on so that works just fine
sometimes you will have one of those
where one of the heroes has an arc and
the other one might be fully evolved and
already living in their essence but most
of the time both characters are going to
have to grow and transform in parallel
simultaneously if you're going to go
into the inner
journey for those characters actually
it's possible to have more than two
heroes you could take a movie like Love
Actually or American Graffiti or any one
of those sort of ensemble kinds of
stories crash and so and they have
multiple heroes a word to the wise if
you're trying to launch a career until
you're well established I generally
recommend against using multiple hero
stories because no matter how good a job
you do scripts with multiple heroes are
hard to read because when we meet them
on the screen no one's going to confuse
in crash Sandra Bullock with whoever it
is Don Cheadle or whoever else might be
in it but it's very easy to confuse a
character named Mary with a character
named Susan we have to keep seven or
eight heroes straight just by their
names on the page and it's also very
complex because you got to carry seven
different heroes through all six stages
and and not give them equal time and
have them all weave together
that's usually something for later in
your career at least after you've gotten
some produced or have some scripts sold
unless you pitch the story and somebody
will pay you to do it but it's it's a
tough kind of script to write just
because of the mechanics of it let alone
because of the artistry involved in
combining them but a to hero story is
very commercial and is fine to pursue
does a hero have to be human can it be a
place can it be an animal and a
borrowing animation but can it be a
place no no no it has to be it has to be
a character it has to be an entity that
that takes action and that is pursuing
some kind of goal every character in the
movie is going to have some kind of goal
they want to pursue it may not take them
all the way to the climax like the
heroes is but it has to be an entity I
don't know how to say it better an
entity that takes action certainly it
can be an animal Zootopia as Judy Hawk
sees the hero and she's a bunny or a
rabbit who's a cop so that's fine it can
be any kind of anthropomorphic character
it could be a cyborg
you know a robot for example or you know
or a is a Spielberg movie or something
like that but it has to be a character
it can't be a place can be a quality it
can't be a collective now the hero
cannot be the resistance the hero cannot
be the villain cannot be the Nazis these
are these are terms that apply to
individual characters
you
take Stephen King's Christine and the
film about the car well well the car
would be the hero that movie would be
whoever that kid was and I'm trying to
stop Christine other I I don't remember
that whatever well okay but if you don't
want to scratch it he would be an answer
for morphic character okay okay cuz it
takes action sure sure we don't know
what roles and talks or whatever you
think so you could could consider it a
character yeah or even kit and Knight
Rider I know we're talking about
television here but kit was a car or
tell you about not only talking about
God so not not bad cinema I think this
is still the current uh film crowd what
are you doing to show the thing is but
we're showing an examples out of how
something doesn't have to be human it
can be it can be a machine that's you
know know the anthropomorphic foot yeah
and what could go wrong come up with so
many good examples
I'm ashamed heroes hello okay Martin
gonna kill yourself but we really want
you to catch this video ever the buzzing
important lessons on everyone's brain
watch out for the Machine heroes you
know okay